hey guys so I've had quite a few people
asking me questions about how the
structure of Oxbridge works so how the
the college system and the department
system works within the university so I
thought I'd answer those questions once
and for all in a video
this might sound obvious to some of you
in which case you're perfectly free to
not watch this video so every student
Oxbridge is a member of a college and
also a student a department or in some
cases multiple departments those two
systems though the colleges and the
departments are completely separate your
college is our new home and it provides
you with a place to sleep
place to eat and library to work in a
common room and a bar your department on
the other hand is where academics in
your subject have their offices and
where they conduct their research it's
often where you'll have your subjects
lectures and there'll be a subject
specific library there more often than
not in some subjects there's also
laboratories on site where you conduct
practical work so to give you an example
you could be a student Oxford because
it's the best university in the world
studying physics because it's the best
subject in the world at some piece it's
because it's the best college and well
then your home your College site is here
on you in Hall Street while your
department where you have your lectures
is up here on Parks Road those two
systems of buildings don't talk to one
another they're completely separate
other than being labeled under the
umbrella term of the University of
Oxford where things get a little bit
more complicated is when it comes to
your teachings but Oxford your teaching
is roughly divided between two systems
lectures and tutorials or supervisions
depending on which university our
lectures are probably similar to your
current experience of Education students
taking your subject from all the
colleges in the university all attend
lectures which will either be held in
your department or in some other central
location like the exam scores in Oxford
for example an academic will stand at
the front of the lecture hall and talk
for an hour about a subject and either
they will give out printed notes that
you can annotate all you can take notes
free hand generally you'll have a
different academic for each lecture
course that you take and electric course
can range from being a single lecture to
being dozens of lectures long tutorials
or supervisions on the other hand are
really quite different and then what
make Oxbridge unique because I have an
Oxford I'm gonna refer to them for the
rest this video as tutorials just know
that in Cambridge they're called
supervisions and because I'm a scientist
I'm going to start by explaining how
tutorials work for scientists and then
I'm going to talk about how they work
for Humanity students because they are
slightly different
as a scientist your lecturers will hand
out periodically properties which
contain quest
based on the material you've been
covering in lectures up to that point
often this is weekly you complete these
questions and at a pre specified date
you hand them in to one of your college
tutors these are members of academic
staff who are associated with your
college and any college will typically
have several tutors for each subject
they can be lecturers professors PhD
students and in some cases they will
actually choose in multiple colleges so
students from multiple colleges will be
tutored by the same person sometimes in
the tutorial you will sit down with your
tutor either individually or with a
group of other people from your college
that do your subject typically one or
two others they'll give you back your
script of attempted solutions marks and
they'll go through the questions showing
you how to do them whilst this is useful
the real benefit tutorials is be able to
discuss the subjects that covered in the
problem sheets with your tutor so for
example I had a problem several problem
sheets on general relativity and one of
my college tutors is a world expert on a
particular pop general relativity and
just being able to discuss the ideas
with him was fantastically useful
because he understood them on such a
deep level that that in some way gets
imparted to you lastly the tutorials
tend to happen either in your academics
office or in a room that they've booked
in your college now in the humanities
because there's more scope for choice in
the courses typically you won't have a
tutorial with a tutor from your college
instead you'll have tutorials with which
other member of the department is a
specialist in the field that is covered
in that tutorial regardless of their
college affiliation that means that you
will typically have to travel to other
colleges to have the tutorials which is
actually a really nice way of seeing the
university also instead of handing in a
property which was set by the lecturers
based on material you've covered in
lectures typically you'll be handing in
an essay which is based on material you
covered in lectures but it's largely
informed by reading that you have done
and tailored to that essay specifically
now obviously this doesn't cover
everything because in some subjects you
have to do translations in other
subjects you have to do well the variety
of things aren't essays all provinces
but this is the general idea of how the
system works I hope that you found this
useful and it's cleared up a few
misconceptions that you might have had
if there are any questions you do still
have feel free to leave them in the
comment section or send me a direct
message and thank you for watching